hi this is presh talwalkar and today
we're going to discuss the cognitive
reflection test which is like a three
question iq test
i'm going to present the questions to
you on the next slide take your time to
read them and answer them
and then we'll discuss the results
so here are the questions
i'm going to move on to discuss the
results but if you need more time just
go back in the video
although these three questions seem very
easy
people don't do very well on them
in a study in 2005
an astounding 83 percent of people
missed at least one question
33 percent of the people missed all
three questions
and even mit students
only 48 of them got all the questions
right
is also an interesting difference
between men and women
this is a quote from the paper that men
scored significantly higher than women
an average of 1.47 versus a 1.03
and this is an unusual result because
men and women tend to score about the
same on all sorts of other standardized
tests
so
how did you do
the answers are
5 cents
5 minutes
and 47 days
i would like to grade yourself honestly
and leave your score in the comment
i have a feeling that mind your
decisions viewers will tend to do better
than average
thanks for watching and please subscribe
to my channel you can also catch me on
my blog mindyourdecisions
on twitter at preshtalwalker and get my
ebooks on amazon